I was at a Lodi to perform for the
troops but mrs. Obama was there on a
more important mission to help promote
the White House initiative joining
forces Harry I'm just hanging out with
the first lady which we do often we do
I'm often standing around with you
Saturday's Saturday's I come by the
White House and you dressed up for me I
dress like a guy doing yard work I
apologize the best I could do it's an
honor to be here you were kind enough to
bring me and several other performers
here kind enough to accept it's an honor
to do this honestly but clearly this is
a labor of love for you why is working
with military veterans and their
families so important to you that seems
to be something that really resonates
with you well it I first came to know
these families on the campaign trail for
my husband's first campaign and I was
blown away by the resilience the courage
the sacrifice that most Americans don't
know about I always say I wish every
American had an opportunity to spend
time on a military base to talk to these
families they would see just how amazing
they are and I came away from my
experience in awe so I vowed that if I
were in this position I use my platform
to shine a light on them where have you
seen the biggest impact our businesses
have stepped up to hire veterans and
military families since we started
joining forces more than 850,000
veterans and military spouses have found
jobs we're working with our medical team
to make sure that these families are
getting the health care that they
deserve we're working with kids military
kids make sure they're getting the
education and support that they need
this feels like a look this feels like a
lifetime project for you as you can see
once you connect yeah you don't wanna
let go it just it just fills you up and
I think every American would have that
experience and you know it doesn't have
to be huge you don't have to be first
lady you don't have to be one of the
funniest men on the planet can we get
that
[Applause]
you have worked so much with the
military you're around military
personnel all the time around incredibly
physically fit men and women and I'm
just curious and you should be honest
with me how do I stack up physically in
your opinion I'll be honest with you
there was a pause actually your body
language was you took a step do you want
to demonstrate you know can't do what
what do you want push-ups
I do push-ups how many do I have to do
50/50 fade-out on
[Applause]
that I'm bleeding now next it was time
to do a meet and greet with the troops
ladies and gentlemen hello the First
Lady of the United States it's not every
day I get to say I was hanging out in a
sports bar with this first lady good
night but I'm sure you'd like to say
something
give it up for Conan I mean amazing let
me tell you know this happened my team
called up Conan's team and it was
literally two weeks out and they were
like yeah and I think weren't you in the
Middle East I had just gotten back from
do I just gotten back from Dubai and I
left you by and I did some shooting in
Armenia and then I went to Dubai
and flew back filming film shooting yeah
I think they know me
they know I'm the physical coward